towards the front that was blocked away one
off full and by's skap it was the dep scoring
it was guys like Travis Boyd getting his first
goal this season carcone as well shot on and a
stop swept away as well by giorgia still in si
Bay are Jack McBain Travis dermit and Barrett
Hatton nushin redot and a stop there by Bender
Conor Ingram and NuSkin gets it right back to
mcken K Kennan at the other end of the ice
turnover here Keller brings it in Keller
holding on to a dishes to the front for Dum
but denied Coyote's got to get back woods got
it over the line Colton and across and they
can't put it on by Conor Ingram once again
and so good for Andre turn's group wicker has
it back out High tried to dumble to the front
hacking at it was kerfoot and a stop by by gorv
on that one and here's the opportunity with the
coyotes in tight curlet right there supported by
valami and taken away to the line Jack Johnson
they get it across toar what a Passad save
Conor Ingram again and now Tatar will pick
it up and he skates in he can't get it past Ingram
McKinnon Galloping again little drop Byam tried to
work it to the front denied rebound and right
there Conor Ingram oh my shut down by number
[Music] 39 and now ran [Applause] in back
out High ma raning it goes down low ransing
it again out of that rightwing corner Mar he
shoots he scores through a screen and it's a
power play goal and the Avalanche with a one-
nothing lead and the could generate a whole
lot and Mar goes just give it to me I'm going to
I'm going to shoot this thing gets it on net and
there's traffic in front Conor Ingram clearly
screened on the play and that's what happens
when both guys wanted to go but making sure
only one goes at a time [Applause] O'Brien
and now Boyd in behind the net left it there
zooker out High Jersy Moser quickly shoots he
scores it bounced in front and the coyotes
have tied it at one Liam [Applause] O'Brian
what a tip Shan Jersey in front he's going to
let this one go and look at Liam O'Brien he
definitely tips this Puck but Travis Boyd might
get a piece of it as well I'm not exactly sure
I think he gets a piece of that as well but
it went up Liam O'Brien's stick high in the
slot right there and dropped that's a big stop
that was a tough save to make Jack Johnson with
a blast and that oneof colon stick in front
floated back to [Applause] Center Cent right
back it over the line here's an opportunity
wood cut to the front he scores oh that's a
power move miles wood the former devil it's
2-1 Colorado yeah wood has been a real nice
addition here in Colorado and here's a perfect
example of it and this line is a lot like that
buad line they just come at you and waves hard
on the puck nice little chip and Chase there
wood gets it and he brings it right to the net OB
absolutely Fearless goes right across that blue
paint no penalty as it's play it around dery
will play it behind the neck JJ Moser high off
the glass goes right to Ma just a magician
with the puck across NuSkin he's robbed by
Ingram Colorado's offensive game and that
really opens up the goenda big push right
to left will'll flip it to the opposite corner
chance to the front and now buad his shot just
ripped wide Lawson Krauss with a spinner
am a shot that goes wide under five to go
power play Let's see Jersy off the faceof win for
Keller and now Keller will set it up right Circle
down low her fooot to the front smoke scores
oh what a setup and a finish and we're tying
it [Music] to [Applause] [Music] Colorado's
[Applause] [Music] [Applause] goenda brings
everyone to him little saucer pass here over the
two ab players right under the Stick of schmalz
who finds that quiet area and he tickles the
twine a one hopper on the stick off the stick
and you got kie back door Keller will pick
it up kessle ring on the pinch kessle ring
will take it away to the front oh and he can't
Keller can't finish it off to the pressure of
the coyotes it's Ma and kessle ring picks it
up thank you very much and gives it to Clayton
Keller back door and jur just gets it you got
that right so Boyd and schz tonight for the
coyotes Ma and wood for Colorado were underway
one will be thrown to the front backhander Krauss
still fighting at it he's finished that second
period out shooting Colorado 10 to one carcone
will chase this one down against Josh Manson
now carcone with a rapper outby Stars Michael
[Applause] [Music] Caron this third period he
beats out the icing gets to the puck Around
the Horn he goes and Chucks it in I think he
goes Far Side on this one post and in you bet
you that is a goal scorers goal right there Mar
across R anony back to Mar and now Ma Ram it in
to the front they bang away and the chw skin
Oh What A play Josh Brown to break it up in
behind Theo and now back out High ma again
across McKinnon scores oh man he picks the
corner oh second power play goal for the ABS
and we're noted at three now McKinnon had a
number of looks but he's been on the left of
Conor Ingram this time he's on the right and
he throws an absolute Dart look at McKinnon
puts it right in the Wheelhouse and you can't
put it any more perfectly in the upper part
of the net short side shelf right over the
blocker nine game streak here tonight the scoring
column for him and the Avalanche will pull it out
McKinnon is right back out ronin's got it
shoot bed Away by Ingram another thought
about it and back out high dersy for Keller in
tight schz schz gets a couple of cracks at it
you got to get G you have a ton of credit
right now he's holding the fork then good
melli now buad tries to put it past they SAR
they snar OT winner in the desert and Off the
Bench come the [Applause] coyotes defending
Stanley Cup champs Tampa the other night the
ABS here tonight one of the hottest teams in
the National Hot we got to give goria a ton
of credit right now he's holding the fort
then good melli now buad tries to put a p
they noar they star OT T winner in the desert
and Off the Bench come the [Applause] coyotes